I would say a bond between the inmate
and the horse is one of the most
important things that they learn when
they actually start to bond to that
horse they will become better trainers
they will become better people I think
that's good that they feel that much
pride in their horses it's good to have
pride in something especially in prison
[Music]
pigs goats right up behind his ears a
little bit with with that rope and when
that gets up there he might jump it's
been pretty good my name is Hank curry
I'm a head horse trainer here at the
Northern Nevada Correctional Center I've
been here 15 years now and I'm in charge
of about 20 to 25 inmates
we're taking a completely wild horse and
trying to domesticate them get them
where they're a gentle usable horse the
inmates put in applications to come to
work out here according to their
behavior in prison we review all of that
and try to decide whether or not they
could possibly become horse trainers to
start out with we take a totally wild
horse and I have my guys actually put
them in a round drill we don't allow
them to rope them or anything else they
have to actually make contact with their
hands most the inmates that maybe
written the horse once or twice in their
life so it takes a lot of guts and it
takes a lot of determination
this guy right here didn't want nothing
to do with me and now he's you know my
little buddy and he follows me
everywhere I go it's just a moment where
you bond you know and you become you
know like best friends this guy only did
within the last few weeks it's pretty
amazing
I mean I'm not doing time until I go
back to him you know and that's when the
clock starts for me as far as realizing
where I'm at when I'm out here I'm free
in the last few years we've developed a
lot of horses that have been used by the
Fish & Game Wardens
the Forestry Service the Sheriff's
Department actually has a amount of
group and those were horses trained by
this program I think that you know this
job is kind of inspirational it's not
like regular prison where everybody's
running around being foul-mouthed you
know being a tough guy and everything
else doesn't work out here horses don't
care who you are how big your house
happier they will equalize the playing
field that you want to play tough I see
it a great deal of change in all these
guys they seem to mature they're
functioning they know how to work you
know how to hold a job so often it's
it's changed their lives
you